my ice cream like chocolate I like pizza
and cheese like a dude is hurt ain't
dance night dance Steven I just got
dance oh my god
[Music]
where's fire team ever podcast episode 3
episode trace bullet point now the
bullet is is yeah what's your take it
even worse the first time you got mad
that I was there was you when I Frank /
x - you got angry was doing
trials not trials of prison of elders
with me Bobby and him and just five
o'clock in one doing
quadrant don't shoot his gun shoot your
guns do you think about quadrant you
know what you one of that is yeah if you
don't do so if he's sponsor you can put
in the matrix you have to shoot yeah
yeah
no but Steve's did this thing where he
would have his rocket launcher out you
know he would have this rocket launcher
out yeah and they're like you're like
Steve switched here and he just waves
with Steve goes in like a blackout okay
see back up Steve's the last guy
standing in the thing you're telling
them things and he's not even I wanna
hit on the ones oh so there was the one
time you got angry at Frank Frank you're
like you were getting killed let me
defend myself if you got a team of
really good players and then you catch a
team of okay players if the team of
really good players does a capture of
one's own but they kill everybody and
don't get killed
you still get points from pills yeah but
I mean you get more points you do but
you got to think if you get if you get
killed if you have a negative teddy
if you get six kills died 12 times and
you're getting you're giving up points
dying the other team is getting points
I'm telling you they always do the math
on me and get 25 I mean if I go if you
go 25 and 5 yeah okay
how many points you get her
get a hundred 100 right so 2500 points
if they have three zones and I died five
times how many point you get 300 to kill
why are we doing was like I'm just
saying like I'm saying it's a gym or
response table it's a positive if I
reader but if you get to zones and you
kill like 10 people you prymaat in the
minute to be aggressive and get sones
you're likely gonna die more so you're
gonna give up more low I mean there's
just different strategies but going back
goes back to team play if you're gonna
you gotta have a bunch of yeah because
I'm going to be trying to let's talk
about what time you get mad when I just
said Steve what what primary are you
that was like going too much in correct
way okay we're talking about that part
of the race is a crotteau oryx or are
you highly you get a death singers curse
or something and you have to go to the
bottom of really but then I didn't know
you have to be right in the middle
on the house the offset yeah so I didn't
know that I thought you just had to be
somewhere in the circle so I [ __ ] up
I'm sorry she was the second time but
there is a Boomer there's a high Boomer
member like oh you have to get your
sniper rifle each one why is it you
never gone off on coke I mean have you
seen them now you went off on me but
what was that was a right 1/8 yeah what
mistakes do I made well you get kills
and no captures you could have gone up
on you like you didn't know no but if
we're talking raid I well that was when
ice I called your character called your
character online a raccoon because you
had the best ones cuz I said I state
your character because you always have
this grow character that has like the
weirdest face paint as I said coke was
laughing we talked about cuz you
everybody was everybody laughed for a
second and then you just went silent no
this is what my mind started it like
this is what was skin how it is well
it's carries about an old friend man
what's yeah yeah we're talking she's 14
she can't defend
[Laughter]
what's scary about it is because you
said you know to me and I didn't think
there was an issue I don't I didn't
think he was mad he didn't talk for two
games was the first thing you said after
it was quiet like was yeah I was I went
off he was and then I said that and he's
like [ __ ] Craig [ __ ] started like I
actually was thinking Steve was mad at
me about the character because you used
to be about the game character did you
realize like after yelled at him and
then like later on or did you realize
and then I know I realized later yeah
well I couldn't get it in everybody was
laughing and then they were so upset
with you getting angry and cred I
couldn't say I was timeout your
character Craig Craig took it till like
Craig was fine because I knew my mom is
like overreaction I'm like Bobby had to
calm him down yeah he's like Bob's
always the one that tries to go down we
even with Griffin that time
Bobby will gas late and then once it
gets crazy I know you gotta bring Steve
to the bridge sometimes by the way the
first time I ever met Steve was over at
Bobby's house cuz Bobby and I and the
reason why we started playing this whole
started because Bobby and I play video
games too
we play fire nobody would play people
all the time and Bobby is like he's he's
a sore loser and an even worse winner so
so he would beat me a FIFA he would send
me pictures of like he would send me the
picture that player so I got his ass
back so when I beat him because he's not
going computers I would like I had a
picture of Fernando Torres yeah yeah no
Taurus was holding his baby and I stood
Bobby's head and I put it on the baby's
head like he never sent me a picture
again and then and then what was great
about it was then Steve and Bobby played
this is over it started with knockout
Kings because there is a thing and you
remember that game yeah and then the old
one this is back in the heyday this but
there's a move we went all 12 rounds but
there's a movie you do a low blow like
hit him in the nuts you go like that and
then the pop star will bend over I mean
you could uppercut and he did that move
on me and I just went red I just [ __ ]
ran to the kitchen and I grabbed two
knives
it is weird like Stan's glass mad TV
audition like if you were he was close
to getting it and when I was a cuz I
would see you this is before we were
playing here destiny Mia body got into
once cuz he had because yeah those two
guys were helping him go through do
flawless and hit him I was like hey can
you guys take me and then I guess they
told Bobby Bobby called me Bobby wounded
by like going painted disappear I don't
make fun of him so much at the store he
just be like one more time no more dates
and I just keep making fun of them
that's true that everybody held the
dates over Frank said that's not cool go
back to red zone I want talking about
coke the other day you oh yeah okay so
it's crazy arrow actually smack rate was
it you know Bobby Bobby was arguing
there
well arrow super cool so like we've been
playing a lot of like arrows one of the
gadget yeah one of the guys we play with
and we're playing like a bunch of
private matches lighting that's all
really you know
our friends we get to compete against
each other so we decided we had some
other dude we were just playing like
skirmish and we played the same team
let's courage 303 is just high trials
same say at the point yes I salvaged but
no point okay so we were playing
skirmish and we beat we beat this team
of two like five times in a row and you
know did destiny or teabag and you know
Justin we start beating Dahlia we start
getting a messages yeah they challenged
us to a tumorous to customize so we're
like I got a message lately what they
say you're trash you know sweaty just
said like they're like we'll beat you -
well that's also him - he sends out
messages to you like I do
so these guys want to do a private match
so we do we do a private match and we we
stomp these things all right so we do a
second one and we're beating him really
bad and I get a message like mid-game
this guy took control him down and took
his phone you know had just to message
me spammy
why are you spamming so many tripmine
connects and I'm like where's that me in
the game it's in the game it does that
mean this guy for everybody knows we
already talking we because you can have
some gone so I was only throwing one
trip mine oh but I was just awesome
beating his ass and so he sent me this
message and then they left the game and
then this guy cuz we didn't have a
closed party
this guy joined our party he just should
we didn't invite him joined our party
and like he's you know trying to act
hood you know trying to like scream at
us through the month like scream he's
screaming you're so [ __ ] your [ __ ]
trash 1v1 me like you're not dead yet
yada yada and we got like a party of
like five people we have not all plane
but like a party of people who are the
other people in the park just other
people friends with air oh oh
my arrow you're given he invites you to
a party I need my people talking I
planned I said yeah I went red because
this guy was like talking tough over a
migrate and I forgot I was twitching so
this was all alive he's just told I'm
stood up started pacing I'm like
[ __ ] [ __ ] you by coming to my
party like he's got a [ __ ] item I got
a video of it I'm sure I'm screaming I'm
like loving cuz he's trying to overtalk
me so I'm screaming I'm like what
[ __ ] you want to do all this
water pumping to school you again I just
beat you like 10 times they're just
[ __ ] losing it on him and these are
two hotheads over yeah I'm actually
scared watching out my damn I was a lot
cuz I was screaming you got your mic on
so like we'll see you can't hear you
can't hear it as well
and I got like one of those like right
on mic like a my boy it's kind of money
and it's loud but it's kind of funny too
because on the feed like your feed right
now doesn't show the other gamers voice
so you just it's like a crazy man some
other [ __ ] to him though to write your
some [ __ ] I said all kinds o then he
backtracked all right he backtracked
because he thought it was someone else
nano right nano and I'm like can you
read [ __ ] and why do you know
who's talking right now this is Phoenix
a UFC he's like oh I thought you were
Nana like shut the [ __ ] up get the [ __ ]
out of my party cool your ass I wonder
like you don't we sit when Jesse 2 comes
out I said I said keep my Phoenix UFC
when destiny 2 comes out I'll [ __ ]
school you in that tune
it's going to school the amount of
hardcore nerdism shirt
[Music]
10 degree 10 degree 10 degree can you
read can you read Nate can you read a
game attack my name is Phoenix USC
[Music]
[Applause]
they're playing video games he's a
gangster look like a shaved peach I want
to hit on I want to hit on their
finishing Steve's Red's always like the
time so I love so you guys hate the
rates you and Griffin especially because
the house a couple times we played the
raids you guys know many rules
yes just like what's frustrating is like
16 hours but I know what it is to for me
and Steve and so you're playing with
these people right you're playing with
five other way
I need to do is on machine voices cuz he
doesn't know is is they so primal but
you go like and then like but then
there'll be long pauses where you won't
say anything cuz you just know you've
done it like funny but then the last
time remember you did that and I I
couldn't help but laugh because I just
expected now and then what'd you do
I don't remember you said boiling 20
minutes ago they were just cracking up a
bust so you can't hear me but that's not
fun
dr. partner Steeve really that one's
hard cuz it's all on you like that like
you get this like orb thing and if you
miss that [ __ ] you have to study it's
done like the whole thing's dead you
have to start the level over like that
segment and so it's really stressful for
how about the one even after that words
like you know you're on there's one
person that like it doesn't it doesn't
randomly select oh thank god so what
have I at the end what the bible that
his whole team has to his hard face
remember the big he's like you see him
his face and then he goes around but
also doing that on hardwood where you
stack the orbs that you yeah I mean
stack the orbs yeah so there's like a
whole system where it's like you have to
like so while everyone's jumping and
stuff you have to kill the orders that
spawn and when they die the olders yeah
once they die they drop this orb and
then you blow those up and I flip does a
little dance but that's what you're
trying to do challenge challenges you
have to do it you have to you like wait
you wait in a while and then like you
have the ogres keep responding that's
the hardest most challenging race it is
there's so many moving parts like like
from the beginning to the end
because if you talk about the relay race
that's nonsense if you know the jumping
is nonsense and those sisters are not
saying oh that thing is not getting you
on the heart like that hard the first
jumping one with the ships yeah like on
the normal one they have that checkpoint
yeah off to the side yeah right with the
hard one they took that away so like if
you fail you're all the way back at the
end and that's what gets you because
when everybody's ahead I think the
pressure just like I know that on Steve
gets to rest when he's about that when
he misses a jump to it so he's like oh
[ __ ] [ __ ] man I like the Steve
surprise which is that there's like a
moment of quiet like the other day we
were playing and we were like hey what's
going on Steve and then you'll hear oh
[ __ ] like when it comes out of nowhere
like we don't even know what you're
doing and then you just means but
recently all we've been doing is playing
ball right because well because that
we're missing one person to play this
was supposed to be Bobby yeah usually
able to give a shout-out we going back
to that what you do I love when Griffin
I love him Griffin and also Bob Griffin
well he when we do something wrong or he
doesn't oh my god
the game is so infuriating oh my god
this is so [ __ ] frustrating oh my god
that was a dog Jesus I love it though
when I try not to laugh but I just love
when Griffin goes like oh my god like so
upset that we [ __ ] or headbutt another
one is when we're playing trials and you
tried to tell us what to do well you
know with the first of all this all
started with Bobbie Bobbie was the first
person it was like and he was yelling
this is from the heyday for the
beginning from the very beginning Bobbie
was getting in trouble with destiny when
it was just the three of us College of
elders and then it's like then it became
the thing where he was like so if
Tommy's not even play anymore where I
keep so that's why yes to mood with so
do yet or move or get in the other room
but his like I'm in the studio I mean
you know fixated on a screen talking to
a bunch of dudes and then they're there
you think you don't you guys about this
but now I got a girlfriend oh yeah
we'll go worthwhile I remember when I
said I had my case so I but so long I'm
packing it to go have a girlfriend saw
like it this is dumb like what are you
doing with this like why are you taking
it that's it this is what I said - I
said well normally what I want to wrote
on chasing hos this keeps me away from
so many times that I've been playing and
I'd be screaming like standing up and
then I would just turn around and I just
see my fiancee just sitting in the
kitchen just staring and then I feel I
feel bad because it's not even the
voices that bother her but my deal was
my monitor was at the head of my are at
the bottom like where my bed sits on my
bed says yeah I know I'm not a big bit I
got a big to you for my bed she's always
like my girlfriend goes destiny you know
that's me the [ __ ] lights are yeah I
thought dim down yeah so like I'm
playing at the foot of my bed and she's
trying to sleep
sure like she's a trooper man she really
is and we've gotten in fights obviously
over it but what's the word fight what's
the worst fight you know just how much I
[ __ ] you know some powers not only
that when I'm injured and I can't really
do anything right like if she's against
it like she's like you're not doing it
and it's not really that I can't do
anything like them just closed at the
time so that's why I'm playing video
game and I think what makes it worse for
them too is that like you know we have
the headset on right yeah so they they
don't hear it's just a weird random
conversation is happening yes
you just hear these with me like new
Clerk I will say so say she she came out
here cuz she came out here yeah and she
met all you guys she's a lot cooler yes
she seemed she just laughed she's like
where's you know so I mean she's likes
everybody she had a good time out here
but also with the relationship thing
what I thought was one of the funniest
things about that that first trip when I
first like met all these guys for
anybody that doesn't know like I know
I'm through the [ __ ] game so the
first time I asked you that worse than
yours first time I met you guys in
person was like a month and a half ago
and it's funny because I'm sitting you
know me and Steve here sitting next to
each other we're talking about destiny
the girls are sitting there talking
about how much they [ __ ] don't like
the light of so loud mean Stevie are
talking about like you know literally in
person talking about the [ __ ] game I
thought it was funny though because you
have like really no I'm using this huh
she she's all about my career so I said
I said I said literally
the time that me and Coke and you are on
and you you were in a fight with your
girl because she was going to it was an
event she was going to and you didn't
want to go and Steve became obstinate
you were like I just told her I'm
hurting I don't go out and he's you
you're so like things like you don't
macho about it like I said I'm gonna
stay engage me I'll get there okay and
then Steve does this thing where he
takes off his headset but he leaves it
dominated he don't mute it so then so we
hear all the way here yes so they from
it wit problems a little bit
going on the world up and then I'm sorry
baby
I'm sitting there yeah buying a second
exports in a second TV so I've like you
can watch your shows on this so I well
yeah I mean it's tough it's tough when
you yes I already have but like I said
but I have to have upstairs dad so I can
go I have my other Xbox I'm like when
she's asleep I just like you know so it
is what it is yeah it's rough
right a number five like that because
because you might talk about you used to
talk about even the bonds in a Labonte
why would she sell shakers no no but you
used to be like nobody's saying I like
all the little stuff in the game later
you meant that one right Bob near the
girls Jayde's neighbor but I said we
please play the game you captain apart
way I played the game so much they're
like like you can do this stuff yeah
they changed up a little bit because
remember when I went from whoever their
original it was the little do feeder
game of wizard thing in the beginning of
the game there was that line the wizards
on the moon and everybody hated that and
so there's no wizards on the moon
well no but they just in it you know the
promise that they may have some like a
robot and he just didn't have like I
don't know it she didn't work for them
so they rerecorded it and then he was
like he only had a certain amount of
time to do it so they will be replaced
him yeah because they made those
t-shirts
well they actors they took all his lines
out and they redid everything right
there in the first game they had like a
whole storyline and everything and then
right before they really like pushed it
they're like one of the heads was like
man and then they [ __ ] that's why
that first destiny game was so like it
was the vex with their first original
enemy like the main enemy right right
please remember that cuz none remember
that Mars mission where you had to like
kill those three Minotaur there's three
of those that was the original like the
end of the game
yeah but then the game became it just
became about upgrading your gear
consumables great about the games they
created they created you know a need for
things like the yeah these missions when
you head to get something that was
really like and then they come in then
it was like nothing in the next update
and then you have this especially with
the story the mistake they made was I
think that they they got rid of it
destiny to they pump more into like the
cinematics in [ __ ] but they took the
cheap route because he's like I don't
know any is actually good if you put all
the story but I don't it is it is
because of candy crush real money I
spent far because I remember I spent $99
because I was like you know I just saw
some you just get this and I was like
and I'm sitting here like what the [ __ ]
am I doing this never ends yeah you're
just continuously upgrading your base
and upgrading your base yeah but I don't
know why I love it nice waiting my buddy
works for ATT at a cell phone store and
he's had
like guys that come in that play those
games like clash of clans and what's in
a Marvel game marble champion service
there was a dude that came in he dropped
over three grand on a key which is crazy
to me because like more there's a base
it may be fun in life your destiny my
destiny is crazy me but destiny you can
I mean you pay for the expansions but
like it's a game that's like very like
wait wait wait hold on hold on oh by the
way they're adding these things to the
games because I play this other game
division yes it's very much like my love
division is one of the funnest kids
because it's such a puzzle with the ammo
in gear sets and all that stuff and like
the weapons is such a puzzle but they're
adding they added to the game just like
where you could buy em the Pacers
destiny tried it too they got that
little area and silver I don't like like
it's not it's not stuff that make the
game and you can buy different stuff but
then there's certain things you can buy
that up you're like you can like your
experience will be 20% more like you're
a more help than stuff and it's like I
look at that and it's like oh there's
like players out there that have to buy
that because they're at the such high
level that they have to come okay
well that's like you and Bob play
fallout like you guys love those
single-player I mean I like it but I
just I can't spend the amount of
destiny's the game I spent the most time
because I cannot spend I just like a
game that you have some camaraderie yeah
my first time I ever experienced this
was Gears of War I used to play Gears of
War all the time but and it was great
when it was just yet you had to like
match what four people so was just four
people so I met these guys in Europe
they were like from England and like
places they were like just and playing
gears and then it became a thing we just
play gears every day
and I even talked about him on TV or my
stand-up thing that I did because it was
just like and I was like oh this is
great and then I did then they expanded
it and I realized the problem with
destiny or not just destiny games like
that is the more people you add to being
able to chat the worse it gets cuz then
no one talks like it's gotta be like six
is about the max yeah yeah that's about
to match cuz like what's the other one
like we're a modern warfare and those
games it's like 25 people and then you
know it's just racial and everybody's
being a dick little kids screaming stuff
so then when you have like a you know
when they get stamps are like a certain
number and then you able to I really
have conversations that's the best part
about it yeah you do this fantastic
gameplay nice to love Gears of War they
had to think on the Horde oh yeah the
Horde coming I think to such a small
area I wish it was like a bigger yeah
he's like a bigger map and make it so
the waves are endless yeah so you tried
it you're always trying to reach a light
they did it like I was like I love call
duty and I never liked Tommy's until
zombies and black ops 2 came out that
[ __ ] was fun as hell because the waves
never ended they just of this race so
the competition was to see how many
rounds you could get to I was hoping
that's what prison of elders were that
would be nuts because then when it first
started it was pretty hard though when
you would get me out of 32 or 34 yeah
right right we weren't that high rank at
that time 30 light level like 31 was the
highest light level you could be so if
you're trying to kill 30 to 34 it
becomes seven hour adventure right but I
know you say it'd be great a fight it
just gets to take level and they're like
yeah but you know a great area for that
is like on the Cosmodrome but when you
do intercept X Prime you know when you
get to the tank part yeah way that setup
where like you're across to feel yeah
then you know like that would have been
a great area
but again they would have done that
would have been like basically yeah
within this game but there's like four
different types of games which is strike
raid submitted to get this nightfall and
a story which but but no one does that
anymore
I know one is saying you have multiple
and will you the one thing I didn't like
that I put down was racing because that
was always something tried it was weird
because they only that's the thing they
do - that's weird they do limited times
and then it goes away
yeah I feel like this game like this
game is so many there's so many moving
parts but I feel like they've changed
everything so so much because it's kind
of like a beta they're trying to because
Bungie does take feedback from what oh
yeah like bitching about and they change
it so like that's why that's which makes
people [ __ ] about so they're always
gonna change right but I do feel like
there's always gonna be people with this
what I like about destiny - and a lot of
the [ __ ] they're doing is like what the
first one should have been yeah they're
adding way more story way more
cinematics with PvE male leg on Patrol
they're making it kind of like World of
Warcraft where you can find a hidden
sector and there's a crazy hard [ __ ]
boss and like really yeah and you get
crazy loot from it on patrol because
patrol yeah
patrolling so they're adding a bunch of
[ __ ] like that so it's gonna be kind of
like a first-person World of Warcraft
and they're gonna they're gonna Wheatley
drop new bosses and [ __ ]
this rule you know keep my okay I'll
just wait and see you know I'm just
saying for like what they're saying like
what's it but the thing is like the
court of Oryx what I thought that what I
loved about that one it needed to be a
bigger space
yeah but what was cool about it was like
you have all these different rulings
bosses bosses in one spot in one spot
but then we played it so much that they
didn't do anything new yeah yeah it's
like it was like all the guys coming out
oh that guy again and then also they
made its that's still the hardest thing
to achieve is to get the third tier the
third tier to get those guys the big box
cuz you have to kill like you to do like
the to do the first one yeah yeah yeah I
get those things and they get to do a
mini proton yes charge to charge it with
my jutsu five times and this everybody
after what people like this what am I
gonna get from it you don't even get
anything from it yeah yeah well hey guys
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]